kenmore and believe nation today's
message is live in the moment over you
misty Copeland I think that when I was
younger I was you know you get so like
antsy and you just want the good things
to come and it's hard to enjoy the
process and I think that something that
I really understand and appreciate now I
mean my life is so chaotic with just
being busy all the time that I literally
just take everything one step at a time
like even when I'm on the stage and I'm
like I can't think about third act I'm
in second act now and I'm going to think
about the piqué arabesque a not have to
do not about the you know the the
pirouettes I'm going to do in two
seconds so it's literally just like
taking everything you know just pacing
yourself and one thing at a time if you
can't learn to appreciate the moment
you'll never be happy I think one of the
things that we as entrepreneurs are
great at is being frustrated with the
status quo is wanting more it's one in
the change something one of the change
the way industry is done because we're
so angry and frustrated with how it's
currently being done and that's great
and that's a strength and that's a tool
you should lean in on it at the same
time though I want you to be grateful
for what you do have to recognize the
abundance of opportunities and wealth
that you have already living the fact
that you are living and watching this
video and have access to youtube puts
you ahead of still most of the world and
recognizing that and being so grateful
that if even if you never accomplished
any more of your goals that you have an
amazing life I think it's helpful now I
don't think it's only focused on how
great everything is so then you don't do
anything else right you don't want to
change things that little bit of
frustration is good but I think you need
both I think too many people don't lean
too hard on the negative on the
frustration on the way things are
currently done and if that's all you are
chasing then you'll never be happy
there's a great story from sticking out
hon where he's talking about washing the
dishes to wash the dishes he's doing
this retreat with his students and at
the end of every night they will go over
to his place and he would make them
dinner
and then he would wash the plate and one
of the guys who came to his session said
hey let me wash the plates for you you
did a lot of work you help us out you've
said us how about I wash the plates for
you and he told them that if you're
going to wash the plates you need to
watch the place you wash the plates to
watch the plates and what that means is
so many times when people are washing
the plate what are you doing you're
thinking of what's next and you're not
actually focused on Washington's like
you're thinking about the conversation
is going to have after you finish
washing the dishes and then when you're
having the conversations after thinking
about what you're going to do later on
that night and when you're actually
doing that thing whether or not you
think about what's going to happen
tomorrow we're so focused and always
thinking about what's next that we don't
take the time to enjoy what's happening
right now I'm enjoying making this video
for you right now I'm entirely focused
I'm just making this video I'm not
thinking about the next videos I'm going
to do I'm not thinking about how I'm
going to send my evening I'm here trying
to be with you in this moment and the
more time you can spend being in the
moment it helps you be a happier and
healthier entrepreneur I think too often
we're focused just on thinking about
what's happening next and we don't
actually get to spend time enjoying our
family enjoying our customers enjoying
the work in the process that we're doing
so if you can take all of that and learn
to be present and yes focus on the
frustration so that helps you become a
better entrepreneur but at the same time
be grateful and mindful in the moment
everything that you do have I think let
me get happier healthier more successful
entrepreneur so the question day today
is I'm curious what do you do is to be
present in the moment cheers to find out
leave in the comments below I also want
to give a quick shout out to Peter Peter
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word really really
means a lot to man and i hope you
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you guys again tomorrow
morning for another shot events beso
I'll give me
a head full of dreams the tour is going
on now you just got off the South
American life yeah i mean when the
crowds the show does it ever how do you
keep it fresh because it's not your
first rodeo it's your thousands ten
thousands i mean even doing it well
here's how I keep it fresh Bruce
Springsteen apparently I don't know if
it really does or not used to say to the
rest of the e street band this could be
someone's first show and it could be
someone's last show so let's treat it
like that so I have that inspiration and
then some other things in my life that
just make me but every time before we go
on stage I really think about like who's
showed up how much they've been through
to get there Wow and also for us at the
moment we're just so into we took a
break from throwing on the last album we
did it called ghost story so we're so
except we're so excited to be there and
we know that nothing lasts forever so I
think that we're just really more than
ever living in the moment and and trying
to appreciate the fact that some people
except for us showing some people you
know in exactly your perspective that
that's not a meteorite you learn and I
work to that perspective yeah we
definitely went through a period about
10 years ago of feeling like what are we
doing you know questioning everything
and not really able to take in the joy
of it that must have been hard it won't
work was I mean everything's in
perspective but after us as a band it
was a bit hard like whatever you know
but but slowly just you keep going and
you find great people who come in and
help you out and teach you things and
and I think the more that you the more
that you let in it's very easy right now
with social media to letting anything
negative you know whatever you do
someone is going to slag it off online
well you're not on social media at all
personnel we are as a plan i don't
really personally to I'm not that good
at self ESA's yeah that's an honest
answer um so so so so I made a decision
that well you know it's easy taking the
bastard so I'm going to breathe taking
the good stuff and appreciate who these
people have shown up and they want to
sing our songs together and that's great
I'm into it I can't ever go I brush it
never gets old that's the thing it never
gets old not meant
goal on your life you're not meant to
say once I get there I'll have it all I
think that that's the biggest lesson
I've needed to learn is how to be
present in that moment and to know that
i'm always going to strive for something
i think everybody who's watched my story
they've seen that not everything has
kind of been handed to me and and I've
been honest about everything some of the
things that haven't been me in the past
and other things I've been so passionate
about and so spot-on with so if anything
that's what revival represents it's that
I feel the most confident I've ever felt
and it goes like that this isn't like
it's constantly changing and I don't
know I think that's just that's what I
want it to feel like your background is
very well documented that the things you
went through which have shaped you how
much of that is really behind you or how
much do those ghosts still haunt you the
the involvement in you know issues that
got you imprisoned and tortured and you
know the drug use and so on I am a
myself and my circumstance i think that
like a spanish philosopher uses to say
so Who am I am a sum of all the
experiences that I lived in my life that
said of course I don't look back because
if i look back at may become a scuttle
of salt so I try to live my life here
but it is the sum of dis good moments
good moments well experiences that I had
in my life that brought me here in front
of your of this camera talking to you
you don't live your life in this
capitalistic sense that accumulate
knowledge has accumulated the money no
no no no life is about the present
moment and you're here you are here now
and then you have an idea we have
something but that may be a routine your
past but you don't know so what I try to
do is to live my life as foolish as
intensely as I can